[Musique]
bienvenue dans vos vies de lecture
nathalie wolf bonjour
sauf que là on va donner des conseils de
lecture notamment pour l'été avec un
invité contador qui est pierre vavasseur
bonjour bonjour bonjour c'est triste
quand on n'a pas lu vous êtes écrivain
vous êtes poète vous êtes journaliste et
vous avez vous êtes un amoureux de la
littérature et vous avez fondé un site
qui s'appelle des minutes de lumière en
plus et je dis un peu ce qu'on peut ici
ça n'est pas compliqué on ne fera que
célébrer le désir le bonheur de lire de
tout des romans des essais la poésie de
l'art de la bande dessinée parce que
lire c'est toujours réveiller la lumière
au plus profond de soi
on a pratiquement tout deal avec votre
je vous ai cités 1 c'est pas juste je
suis d'accord avec ça vous êtes d'accord
avec vous même ne rien
il ya un grand nombre de deux par un je
ne peux pas tous les citer mais ya marie
nimier ya jean rouaud ya pascal ory
l'irene frein ya sylvain tesson tatiana
drones et jérôme garcin marc lévy jean
marie gourio mon combat chief les deux
corners katherine pancol nathalie rheims
jean christophe rufin daniel picouly
c'est à dire ça va dans toutes les
sphères de la littérature de la plus
populaire et la plus exigeante
ça c'est formidable aussi d'avoir ça
c'est ce que ça vaut bon d'abord suivent
suis vraiment vraiment fier et honoré
c'est pas de mots dans le vide quelques
qu'il rejoint fait tous ces gens mais
rejoint l'on n'attend héritant matin
eric giacometti par exemple un autre
genre qu'il soit là et et oui c'est ça
il n'y a pas un jean vinet pas que ça
soit cermeno pratin de chez
germanopratin weeds que ce soit que yves
viollier arithmétique il ya tous les
genres et unit sont là et encore une
fois je suis très reconnaissant à tous à
tous les parrains et marraines moi
j'aime bien dire à tous ménard année
mais par n
mais c'est compensé sur les fonts
baptismaux de cette histoire je vraiment
je pense qu'on va faire des folies chose
je voudrais c'est gentil vous évoquez ce
site parce que ce que je voulais me
lancer
c'est ouvrir deux maximum les led pour
couvrir ben voilà tout pour parler le
plus possible de ce qui est tout ce qui
nous tient de ce qui nous tient à
l'intérieur ce qui nous tient debout qui
est pour moi ce qui me concerne c'est la
littérature ce que les mots et alors
après l'avalanche qui l'avalanche à
gérer c'est une autre histoire mais on
va y arriver à baillargues et oui c'est
ce qui nous tient le plus à coeur à nous
aussi avec envies de lecture les livres
et les mots alors pour cet été on va on
va on va découvrir quelques conseils que
vous allez nous donner est tout d'abord
on va parler de la marge d'erreur de
nicholas ray bah ouais c'est un livre
dont je suis tombé amoureux vraiment
tombé amoureux au sens propre du terme
sens le plus intérieur aussi du tarn
vous savez nicholas ray cette wilaya
en 2000 il a eu le prix sport
directement et on va vivre
pour mémoire la mémoire courte voilà
pour un livre qui qui avait 11 n comment
dire qu'il y avait là des aides tout ce
qu'elle écrit qu'il avait mûri après et
puis une sorte de comment dire de style
un peu dilettante mais qui n'était pas
dilettante
c'est que j'ai inventé j'inventais une
formule pour nous après le don
dilettante
parce que inouïe c'est vrai parce que
comme ça ils veulent un rythme il un
recul sur tout et il devait un recul
avec humour et cette politesse du
désespoir c'est pas un homme plein
d'espoir nicolas c'est un type qui est
assez désespérée et moi j'adore ces gens
là parce que c'est ce niveau le plus
d'humour et le plus de
2 qui survole de mieux les chemises et
maintenant il en est je pars compte est
bon - dixième roman et ce roman je pense
au salon de dire c'est son meilleur nick
leeson les journalistes c'est le
meilleur de tout ce qu'il a fait c'est
un roman d'une puissance de tir énorme
avec hongrie mais j'ai ri aux éclats des
fois et on est sincèrement auprès des
membres de verser notamment avec la fin
que je ne vous en dirai plus quand même
sur l'histoire oui c'est un dépressif
non je suppose parce qu'il se trouve en
face à valdes dépressive
[Rires]
c'est normal je sais mieux dépressif que
des primes et lance un dépressif heureux
mais là des bonnes raisons en même temps
vous savez pas ce que son personnage ici
qui s'appelle gabriel salins qu'à 47 ans
et qui qui qui est journaliste il ya
délit ad c'est françois les interviews
dans ce petit livre là je dis petit pas
de plus de 600 pages
les séquences d'interviews kiki qu'il a
sans doute vécu je crois reconnaître
bernise les eaux alors donné qu'ils sont
formidables qui vous font rire il ya des
conversations du dialogue incroyable
donc en tout cas et la direction d'eads
et pacifique revenir parce qu'il est
malade et de valence
c'est pas dans la vie vraiment nicolas
export
il le dit par once pas un secret il a
des anciens céramique il est tout cassé
à l'intérieur et là gabriel salaire en
plus il a un cancer des poumons à ses
futurs ans et le psychologue depuis
qu'il en a avec nicolas pas du tout avec
nicolas rey à ce que puisqu'il a fait
comme à vivre il va il va arrive à
raconter cette histoire qui tente de
cimenter du cancer cécité 700 amoureuse
qu'il quitte et qui lui dit j'ai
rencontré qu'à ce moment là comme il dit
très bien je suis un fantôme perdu dans
un terrain vague
ça c'est du pur n'y paraît ce genre de
phrases ça vous prend aux tripes et
l'idée est alors on va assister à une
sorte de comédie de trades maudit
dramédie pour dire entre son désir de
vivre à fond les médicaments dont
barrage perdu et puis qui l'entourent
ce n'est pas spoiler de dire qu'elle va
revenir mais entre-temps il a rencontré
ses oasis appel diane était une femme
formidable qui lui redonne absolument le
goût de la vie de l'amour et
pardonnez-moi nos psys du sexe parce
qu'avec tout le monde connaît ne plus
avoir d'érection ya une autre scène très
amusante rédacteur en chef d'envoi au
bénin et au bénin est un sorcier on lui
explique qu'il faut aller voir le
sorcier pour qu'il recommence avoir
dévissé ligue la boum et et ça c'est pas
tout de suite mais ça va se faire après
pour donner lieu à des scènes de sexe et
pas de mots est celle d'une sensualité
d'amour on n'a jamais aussi intimement
quelques tel qu'il le fait est qu'ils
sont c'est pas des scènes de sexe et
d'amour ce sont des coupures d'amour
physique c'est formidablement écrit
c'est une fluidité it
encore une fois d'un déplacement est de
800 aussi d'un très grand livre à lire
cet été qui plaira aussi bien aux hommes
qu'aux femmes parce qu'encore une fois
sa peur de l'amour absolu
nicolas nicolas rey c'est un grand
romantique une équipe qui n'est plus de
rien la marge d'erreur dans de nicholas
ray cette audition du diable vauvert
alors deuxième livre claude igad et
avant l'été ces actes sud on l'a connue
elle pour les déferlantes qui avait été
le grand prix de l est qui a été un
grands best-sellers 300000 exemplaires
vendus d'un cousin tout de suite quand
il est arrivé c'était son cinquième
livre son sixième livre dont l'un l'a
déjà écrit cinq élèves sont tous
premiers annoncés la suite parce que son
tout premier set troubles dys le sublime
c'est l'office des vivants quand même
retrouvé ce titre c'est quelque chose
est en fait le voeu de cuivre sans notre
question c'est de raconter aux fins
évidemment comme tout le monde en était
la pire les hommes kalos t elle le sait
n 9 toujours au sein d'un groupe
roddick il faut en fait être et résister
s'accommoder de ce qui nous a construit
et bien c'est exactement ça histoire de
ce concours ont été un moment d'entre
elles vous savez une première du film
dont dev bien nous et ce sont cinq
jeunes femmes dans les années 80 elles
ont elles sont juste au moment où la
vivre vraiment départ et aux filles en
lob désir entre ambition et c'est ce
sont des femmes modestes pas sur l'or et
ce sont surtout des copines d'enfance et
un dans le pays' solidaire en tout
lancement ces oppositions de la
narratrice est un péché sitter on se
défile dans la création d'un défilé de
mode ont confondu création aura fait le
cadre de la petite ville donc cette
épouse mince je suis et mon fabriquer
des robes on voit encore en cours on
brode au pic en tout le poids contre le
tout libre mais c'est surtout un livre
elle sait pas surtout c'est que c'est
donc le coeur d'un livre ce qu'elle
devient aussi l'amitié vous aime dire ça
pour appeler à la vérité rend cette ça
pour elle ne savait pas c'est parce que
c'est sophie hunger
celui d'un gsm arrêté pour s'être l'on
va vouloir passer au troisième bientôt à
un point où voilà alors parmi ces 5 600
m2 qui ont une dignité une amitié est
née au cnrc ahmad total juillette la
plus jolie des simples si on veut dire
comme ça sans ameuter nitoo c'est elle
qui le dit et est la narratrice qui est
gesca et qui autour de cet ami tellement
tellement forte sans fin comme ça qui
est toujours frotter comme du silex
évidemment c'est une amitié 3 y ait
autant de stars pinceau second seulement
se développer et il ya eu il ya une très
belle séquence sur qui porterait à robe
de mariée dans ce défilé de noël
en tout cas c'est un livret qui est
construit un petit chapitre
c'est ça le talent de lady gaga ce sont
des chiffres très bref qui s'enchaînent
les uns les autres et qu'ils vont
chercher au cran tout à l'heure on
parlait de médecins non chercher au fond
de la scène au plus près du coeur ce qui
nous construit encore une fois et
comment on s'accommode de la crainte du
lendemain c'est vraiment une très belle
avant l'été de claudie gallay c'est un
gros livre un éleveur everlast pour
l'été s'est pas ouvert contre 946 pas
commencé début juillet mais il nous
reste à peine une minute mais tu milites
appelant pour parler de d'alain baraton
et son fameux dictionnaire je suis pas
peur chez plon
on connaît très bien ici alors écoutez
je sais non j'ai pas fait exprès puisque
il est de votre tribu 6 pu dire
jardinier en chef du domaine national de
trianon du grand parquet de versailles
alors c'est magnifique c'est un livre
c'est un livre c'est aussi une histoire
d'amour où les arbres évidemment et puis
qui raconte tellement de choses sur la
la multiplicité des caractéristiques des
arbres sur les ifs sur les séquoias son
échiquier
j'acquiesce et des fruits de 30 à 40 kg
oui j'ai noté plein de petites choses
comme ça le vif c'est le symbole
d'éternité
on en voit beaucoup dans les cimetières
l'un des plus vieux se trouva le
n'attendais que je me dise pas de
bêtises l'un des plus lourds en tout cas
c'est un séquoia qui fait kiffer 2500
tonnes
un autre citoyen fait 115 machines
mobiles rival soigner des hémorroïdes
mais les figuiers d'amérique du sud sont
des petits à raison de 120 m de racines
de la définition de veaux croisés et
sauces pour la route en cette lettre oui
platanes
alors justement ont justement baraton
raconte comment des platanes ça a été un
problème entre pompidou et j'abandonne
masse si vous ouvrez vivo d'airé pour
quoi parce que pompidou boulet défendent
tous les plats et puis là là l'épousé
chaban delmas s'est tué ses trois salles
de pompidou du coup revu sa copie l'y
obligeait mais vous lirez aussi nous
vient la palme d'or de cannes d'où vient
cette panne et qui ses fans qui
s'étaient cnar qui s'appelle le kama et
doha élégance et qui sert aussi à faire
les dollars en tout cas c'est plus qu'un
gros c'est pas nous c'est magnifique
merci infiniment pierre vavasseur merci
beaucoup il fige rappelle une hausse des
minutes de lumière en plus c'est le blog
sur lequel repose vous retrouver quand
on veut et comme on veut merci beaucoup
et demi merci beaucoup patrice merci
métal
[Musique]